(upbeat music)
- The first time I met Miss Louise?
Never shall forget it.
We met eye to eye, you know,
and that must've been
love at first sight.
- [Narrator] This is Charles "LaLa" Evans.
- All right, here we go. (laughs)
- [Narrator] He and his wife Louise lived
in this house in Starkville, Mississippi.
- We were married 59 years and 11 months.
And we were one month shy of 60 years.
We almost made 60.
- [Narrator] After she died, LaLa created
a unique tribute to her.
- I decided I'd do this in memory of her.
And we call this LaLa and Louise's Place.
- [Narrator] It's his
personal memorial to Louise
made up of thousands of photos.
- This is it.
This is it.
Everywhere we went we
took pictures, you know.
"You stand over there, that
oughta make a good one."
"You stand over here,
that'll make a good one."
"Hold it, hold it, hold it."
Click! (laughs)
We had talked about it before she passed
that one day we wanna build a museum
to put these pictures in.
We didn't get a chance to do that,
but the idea never left my mind
and so I said I'm gon' do it anyway.
This was 1968.
We were goin' dancin' somewhere.
Back in those days
dancin' was a big thing.
When I first met my
wife she couldn't dance
and she just got tired of that.
She said, "You gon'
teach me how to do that."
And after I taught her we
were such a smooth couple,
you know, we didn't miss a beat, man.
This is my 33 collection.
Four Tops, look at that, the Four Tops.
Ohio Players.
45 city.
- [Narrator] Would you and Louise dance
to some of these records?
- Oh man, yeah.
Did we?
(laughs) Shoot.
Yes, we did.
(somber orchestral music)
This right here, our last dance.
I'll never forget it.
It was in July
and I took her,
spinned her around, dipped
her for the last time,
brought her back up, (kissing smack)
put one of them on her, you know?
The following Friday is when
she had a massive heart attack
and she wasn't responding, you know.
All of a sudden she looked up at me
and said, "I love you,"
and that was it.
Okay.
Changin' of the guard.
We had such a beautiful life.
I got so much to remember
and I'm just livin' a beautiful memory.
Yeah.